what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday
in the midst of the eternals trailer
releasing we actually got some pretty
big spider-man no way home news
and it looks like we're getting closer
and closer to getting our very
first look at spider-man no way home the
teaser trailer could drop
anytime within the next two months but
before that it looks like we're going to
be getting a
teaser of a teaser we are going to be
getting a little preview of
spider-man no way home and we're getting
it this week
but what exactly should we expect from
this preview
and what should we expect from the
actual teaser when it comes out well
that's what we'll talk about
in this video and i should also note
that we're also going to be getting a
tiny
little preview of chongqi the eternals
4-4
black widow and a little bit more from
marvel's phase 4. that is all happening
this week and less than a week for my
stormbreaker giveaway to enter just
subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture it ends on the 31st
well all right like i mentioned the
other day when we found out that the
spider-man no way home merchandise was
starting to go on sale
this means that marvel studios and sony
are getting ready for the promotion of
no way home which means the teaser is
close
and like i just mentioned we're actually
going to be getting a preview of
spider-man knowing home and that preview
is going to be coming to us
on friday and it's going to be coming to
us from total film
magazine now total film has done a lot
with marvel in the past they did a lot
for avengers in-game
and pretty much all of the marvel
projects that have come out recently
and they have a big marvel phase four
article coming out this friday it's
specifically going to focus on tom
hiddleston's loki however it is going to
talk about other marvel phase 4 projects
and it
is going to give us a preview of a few
projects
one of them is spider-man no way home
now we actually have the cover of the
magazine
and it does indeed say that we will be
getting a preview as you can see we have
loki on the front and we're definitely
going to be learning a little bit more
about loki in this magazine but if you
look at the top
it says marvel preview and then under
that it says shanxi
eternals spiderman thor 4 black widow
and more i'm hoping the more could be a
little bit of information about the
fantastic four but i'm not holding my
breath
but you can see that it specifically
says
spider-man right under marvel preview so
we're getting a preview for spider-man
no way home but what does this mean
well for starters i'm not really
expecting a picture of toby maguire
andrew garfield and tom hiddleston all
standing together in their spider-man
suits this is definitely not how they're
going to reveal that
but could they reveal some other things
about the movie absolutely what i'm kind
of expecting
is some pictures of tom holland
spider-man and perhaps him with doctor
strange
and they definitely could throw in
alfred molina or jamie foxx's electro
because if i'm the studio
i know that the audience and the fans
they already know that these two
characters are in the movie so why not
tease them a little bit and we could get
a photo of perhaps tom holland's peter
parker looking very confused
off into the distance they won't show us
what he's looking at but of course we
can speculate that that might be
another spider-man again we probably
won't learn too much about toby mcguire
and andrew garfield's involvement in the
film
from this article but what this means is
that the trailer
really is coming soon and some people
are actually speculating that
next week only a few days after this
article is going to come out
is tom holland's birthday it's june 1st
and then on june 2nd
is kevin feige's birthday the president
of marvel studios and there's a lot of
speculation about this right now because
they released the xiang chi
trailer on sema leo's birthday now of
course that doesn't mean that they're
going to release the trailer
on tom holland's birthday because that's
what marvel does now that's not the case
but the trailer is definitely coming
within the next two months and promotion
has started for it so who knows it could
come any time now
and after all that is the next teaser
trailer that we are supposed to get the
shanxi trailer was
a month ago and that movie is coming out
in september we just got the eternals
trailer yesterday and that's coming out
in november
the next movie is spider-man away home
coming out in december
so we could logically think that the
spider-man no way home trailer is
about a month away based off of the
current pattern of marvel releasing
trailers
however and not to get everybody's hopes
up i would keep an eye out next week
just in case they decide to drop it on
tom holland's birthday or kevin foggy's
birthday
regardless we are getting a tiny preview
of the film
this friday and the trailer is right
around the corner so
not much longer to wait so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest spider-man no way home videos to
update you
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof